Hank: ♫ The hidden moon is rising over Forks, Washington  ♫
♫ and suddenly you shy away from my body's warmth.♫
♫ My muscles are hard as I can make 'em,  ♫
♫ but that's not enough for you. ♫
♫ You want me to be cold and hard like a moving marble statue. ♫
♫ The only thing that you think you need ♫
♫ is the one thing that I can never be. ♫
♫ You don't love me 'cause I'm not Edward Cullen. ♫
♫ I can wear sparkly makeup and act all brave and sullen, ♫
♫ but you can't help but realize these are golden contacts in my eyes. ♫
♫ So you think you can't be the one and only girl for me. ♫
Katherine: ♫ Only one man can protect me from harm. ♫
♫ Plus, a hundred years of investment made him richer than God.  ♫
♫ For a century he saved his virginity for me. ♫
♫ And I know all about that girl you scored with in 2003. ♫
♫ He's the only man that I can't resist ♫
♫ and you can't convince me he does not exist. ♫
♫ I can't love you 'cause you're not Edward Cullen. ♫
♫ You can wear sparkly makeup and act all brave and sullen, ♫
♫ but I can't help but realize those are golden contacts in your eyes. ♫
♫ So you can never be the one and only boy for me. ♫
Hank: ♫ It's so superficial that you love his fancy cars ♫
Katherine: ♫ but Edward Cullen also never ever has to fart. ♫
Hank: ♫ I hope someday his child will rip its way outta your womb. ♫
Katherine: ♫ Give up now and we can still be friends, I'll never fall in love with you. ♫
Katherine: ♫ The only thing that I really need ♫  Hank: ♫ The only thing that you think you need ♫
Katherine: ♫ is the one thing that you can never be ♫ Hank: ♫ is the one thing that I can never be ♫
K: ♫ I can't love you 'cause you're not Edward Cullen. ♫ H: ♫ You don't love me 'cause I'm not Edward Cullen. ♫
Katherine: ♫ You can wear sparkly makeup ♫ Hank: ♫ I can wear sparkly makeup ♫
Katherine & Hank: ♫ and act all brave and sullen, ♫
K: ♫ but I can't help but realize those are golden contacts in your eyes ♫                                                         H: ♫ but you can't help but realize these are golden contacts in my eyes ♫
K: ♫ so you can never be the one and only boy for me. ♫ H: ♫ so you think you can't be the one and only girl for me. ♫